it just breaks my heart it is the one
thing I was hoping wouldn't happen
another member of the Cuomo family has
tested positive for the corona virus for
weeks Chris and his wife Christina have
been battling with kovat 19 it's very
rare for a family to be one and done and
now their 14 year old son Mario is
fighting the virus as well being a
mother having gone through Lyme disease
having seen others suffer through
different ailments you know I realized
that it's all about our health if we
don't have our health there nothing
matters Christina shared the
heartbreaking news on Wednesday with
Instagram pictures of her son writing
after 10 days of ups and downs feeling
good one day and terrible the next I am
now working hard to get my son Mario
through the virus my heart hurts more
than my head over his infection the mom
of three continued to remind people that
the virus doesn't discriminate and even
though kids are more resilient they can
suffer the same severity of symptoms for
instance Christina shared that Mario had
lost his sense of smell and taste
she said she's now feeding him healthy
foods that he normally wouldn't even
touch christina also noted that she's
applying a modified version of her
remedies for his protocol and is focused
on giving him lots of vitamins he
recently caught up with Christina and
she opened up about her and Chris's road
to recovery and of course you know the
six thousand milligrams of vitamin C a
day I think is mandatory and also the
breathing exercises that I do with my
friend who's a yoga instructor yes
you're helping your lungs and your whole
breathing but you're also helping you
your mental health that's really
important right now people have been
feeling really debilitated by this virus
mentally just like Christina chris has
been admirably open about his battle
with a virus push ups slow the
journalist has shared glimpses into his
workouts on Instagram as he continues to
men
and on Tuesday the CNN anchor officially
emerged out of his quarantined basement
all right here is the official bridge
from the basement cleared by CDC little
sway just workout happens this is what
I've been dreaming of literally for
weeks
my wife she was cleared by the CDC and
have fevers anymore in the video Chris
thanks his wife and his kids including
Mario for holding down the house thank
you for being so nice to me thank you
for taking care of everything you had to
thank you for taking care of me and
Bella thank you for stepping up I was
really impressed with her the first
morning or I could barely out of bed she
was giving Chris his vitamin C and
glutathione and all of his special
remedies too she had Mario doing all
sorts of things feeding the dogs you
know cleaning up after himself and
gathering laundry and taking the clothes
that they've been wearing the day before
when they were exposed to me and putting
it on the laundry so she really stepped
up in a big way
[Music]